bonjour à tous
138 milliards d'euros c'est le montant
du déficit budgétaire de la france en
2009 un budget fortement marquée par la
crise économique et par le plan de
relance qui en a découlé
hier la commission des finances du sénat
a débuté l'audition de certains
ministres sur leur budget de l'année
passé des auditions qui vont servir à
l'examen du projet de loi de règlement
pour 2009 c'est à dire la validation
définitive du budget de l'année écoulée
michèle alliot marie la ministre de la
justice a été la première à répondre aux
questions des sénateurs
elle a donc dû expliquer et justifier
l'utilisation et la répartition des
crédits alloués à son ministère en 2009
des crédits qui ont notamment servi à la
réforme de la carte judiciaire et à la
rénovation des prisons
on écoute cette audition merci
infiniment d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
nous vous avons convié un exercice que
vous connaissez bien puisque vous l'avez
déjà vécu dans dans vos différentes
fonctions ministérielles il s'agit pour
la commission des finances élargie à
l'ensemble des commissions ayant tarde à
se saisir pour avis de des moyens mis à
votre disposition il s'agit une audition
avant la loi de règlement pour que vous
nous éclairer sur l' usage que vous avez
fait des crédits mis à votre disposition
pendant l'année 2009
et donc que l'exercice prend la forme de
questions et de et de réponses ont
peut-être que d'abord je voudrais saluer
la présence parmi nous de jean rené
lecerf qui est rapporteur pour avis
pour l'administration pénitentiaire et
remercier nos collègues de la commission
des lois qui nous ont rejoints peut-être
peut-être une première question si vous
le permettez à propos de la réforme de
la carte judiciaire qui s'accompagne
d'un volet immobilier important évalué
par la chancellerie à 375 millions
d'euros
pouvez-vous clarifier les conditions de
remise à disposition des crédits au
profit de votre ministère par le biais
du compte d'affectation spécial
immobilier à la suite des cessions
d'immeubles opéré par france domaine
quel jugement portez vous sur les délais
de mobilisation de ces crédits issus de
ce compte d'affectation spéciale et la
ressource effectivement obtenus par le
par ce canal en 2009 correspond elle aux
besoins et aux engagements qui avaient
été pris à l'endroit de votre ministère
messieurs voici donc d'abord merci de
votre accueil je voudrais vous dire que
c'est toujours pour moi un plaisir de
venir discuter des crédits devant la
commission des finances d'une façon
générale de venir discuter des budgets
devant les commissions compétentes
ce que je veux simplement que précisé en
commençant c'est que il s'agit là
effectivement de budget de crier nos
c'est une différence par rapport à
d'autres exercices que j'ai fait et
surtout c'est là peut-être la différence
principale de budget que j'ai pris en
cours d'exercice est triennal puisque
même le budget 2009 que j'ai eu à mettre
en oeuvre à partir du mois de juillet je
ne l'avais pas vraiment je n'y avais pas
vraiment que participer avant peut-être
de répondre mais très rapidement à votre
question je voudrais juste vous faire
part de quelques observations que j'ai
pu faire en arrivant dans ce ministère
sur le fait en particulier que les
budgets du ministère sont dépendants un
peu d'une situation qui remonte à
plusieurs décennies et pour avoir vu
d'autres ministères j'ai pu constater
que les efforts qui avait été fait les
efforts financiers les personnes à elle
fait dans d'autres ministères n'ont pas
été faits à proportion au ministère de
la justice et dans le même temps que
l'on constate aussi et au cours de ces
dernières années cela ne fait que
s'amplifier une augmentation sensible
des activités de la justice c'est ainsi
que par exemple en matière d'affaires
civile entre 2002 et 2008
les affaires le nombre d affaires a
augmenté de 58% en ce qui concerne les
décisions rendues en matière pénale nous
avons un taux de progression de 10 % et
un taux de réponse pénale qui progresse
de 68 à 81 5%
or dans le même temps les augmentation
du budget du ministère de la justice
même s'ils se sont améliorées et très en
retrait de cela puisque ça ne représente
finalement et qu'une augmentation qui
est de l'ordre de 5%
c'est donc là juste une illustration que
des contraintes qui sont celles de ce
ministère alors je reviens bien entendu
à votre question puisque les moyens de
la justice doivent s'adapter aussi et
prendre en compte une modernisation de
l'état que l'on a cherché à faire dans
tous les domaines y compris avec la rgpp
et la carte judiciaire correspond à la
fois à une volonté de rationalisation et
d'adaptation de la présence judiciaire
sur le territoire prenant en compte les
évolutions démographiques des
territoires les évolutions d'activité
aussi sur les différents territoires qui
se traduit par une réduction d'un
certain nombre de cadres de l'activité
judiciaire et tout ceci dans une
perspective effectivement qui est celle
d'avoir la meilleure adaptation possible
des moyens ou ressources
alors en ce qui concerne le compte
d'affectation spécial immobilier
comme vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le
président les besoins liés à la réforme
de la carte judiciaire ont été fixés à
375 millions d'euros sur la période
allant de 2009 à 2013 et les ressources
pour faire face à ce besoin sont
attendus à la fois sur le budget général
et d'autre part sur le compte
d'affectation spéciale immobilière alors
en ce qui concerne les encaissements
au bénéfice du crs immobilier judiciaire
nous en sommes à 3,53 millions d'euros
en 2009 pour 2010 aujourd'hui le
ministère ne connaît pas la dotation
d'être conforme à la lettre du premier
ministre
40 immeubles relevant de la direction
des services judiciaires sont
actuellement en cours de cession pour
une valeur vénale qui est estimé à 16 47
millions d'euros
je vous rappelle que contrairement à ce
qui se passe à la défense nous ne
récupérons pas la totalité des ventes
mais seulement 65 % du prix ce qui veut
dire que nous devrions récupérer environ
17,7 millions d'euros dans l'hypothèse
où les ventes seraient réalisées en 2010
c'est donc ce montant qui serait affecté
au financement de la carte judiciaire
est ce que je veux dire c'est également
c'est que tu ne fasses sont que plus
générale le montant des actifs
immobiliers que le mystère la justice a
donné à france domaine se monte à 126
millions d'euros 115 millions ne sont
ils pas une surévaluation à non je ne
pense pas que les 375 millions d'euros
est une très belle émotion et parce que
nous avons effectivement une
multiplicité de besoins qui sont liés en
particulier à la nécessité de retrouver
des locaux pour accueillir les
personnels qui viennent d
des juridictions qui sont fermés et là
c'est parfois est extrêmement lourd
parce qu'en plus les juridictions
maintenu la plupart du temps sont en
centre ville et elles sont déjà elle
même assez à l'étroite donc il faut soit
reconstruit reçoit et tendre soit
acheter un certain nombre de locaux
supplémentaires pour pouvoir être que
lorsqu'on se déplace nous étions à
quelques semaines
oui ça mais c'est dans le pas de calais
et bien arras 1 race à part et non une
partie des immeubles sont achetés par le
conseil général pour les besoins de la
justice est ce que c'est une pratique
qui se généralise
c'est une pratique que nous essayons que
d'obtenir dans toute la mesure du
possible malheureusement elle ne se
généralise pas suffisamment en tous les
cas mon goût mais si vous le voulez
monsieur président moi je peux tout à
fait vous communiquer la liste des
opérations qui sont prévues correspondra
ça c'est si vous le souhaitez vous aurez
les détails
c'était la première réponse je rapporte
à générale le président trois questions
trêve si vous me permet de faire madame
ministre
en premier lieu pouvez vous nous résumer
les mesures prises au titre de la rgpp
en 2009 et l'évaluation des économies
budgétaires réalisées grâce à ces
mesures
enfin en termes d'équivalent temps plein
travaillés de crédit en second lieu et
c'est notre visite à arras qui me donne
l'idée de cette question et la récente
loi sur la protection de certaines
catégories de deux personnes
représente sans doute un défi pour les
juridictions comme pour les organismes
de tutelle et pouvez vous nous en dire
un mot avec en particulier les enjeux
budgétaires liées à la mise en oeuvre de
cette législation
et en troisième lieu s'agissant de la
récente loi pénitentiaire
elle encourage le travail en milieu
carcéral et ses encouragements ont-ils
été concrètement suivies d'effet dès
et là encore quels en sont les
incidences budgétaires sur le rapporteur
général rgpp porte effectivement se
traduit par des mesures qui affectent à
peu près tous les services du ministère
de la justice
aussi bien que la centrale que les
différentes directions dans ces mesures
rgpp il y a donc la carte judiciaire
dont je viens de vous parler et il y a
également la rationalisation de la
protection judiciaire de la jeunesse qui
se traduit en particulier par le
regroupement en centres interrégionaux
d'un certain nombre de centres régionaux
le sait suscite parfois une certaine
émotion
cela se traduit d'ailleurs également
c'est une autre de mes préoccupations
dans le cadre de la rgpp même s'il
n'était pas directement inscrits par une
de clarification des répartitions de
compétences entre l'état et les
collectivités territoriales
puisque en particulier en ce qui
concerne la protection non pénale si je
puis dire de la jeunesse la loi de 2003
normalement en faisait une compétence
des conseils généraux et elle n'avait
pas été et toujours mises en oeuvre donc
nous avons là des traductions qui
s'opèrent qui se concrétise en termes de
fermeture de centres mais également de
diminution de personnel en ce qui
concerne l'administration centrale par
exemple il ya toute la dématérialisation
et l'informatisation sur lesquels nous
avons dû refaire un certain nombre de
travaux parce que il y avait beaucoup de
retard il y a eu des malfaçons dans
l'informatisation nous avons donc re
négocier avec les opérateurs concernés
là aussi c'est un travail extrêmement
important un travail qui sur les trois
ans à venir va effectivement amené un
certain nombre de réductions de postes
ceci dit le véritable problème c'est que
les premières années on ne peut pas
réduire les postes dans la mesure où le
système informatique n'est pas
totalement au point
le 3e louis de la carte informatisation
et en ce qui concerne la pénitentiaire
en silence et de la pénitentiaire mon
objectif même s'il n'est pas directement
inscrit dans la rgpp à côté même des
efforts très importants qui sont faits
pour l'ouverture de nouveaux
établissements
c'est de recentrer aussi les personnels
et notamment les personnels
pénitentiaires sur leur coeur de métier
c'est un phénomène général que nous
constatons dans tout le ministère de la
justice de personnels qui sont affectés
notamment à des tâches administratives
ou à des tâches techniques qui ne sont
pas celles pour lesquelles ils ont été
formés et je pense que c'est là un gros
gaspillage à la fois de compétences mais
également d'argent parce que quand un
gardien de prison
avec toutes les rémunérations qui
s'attache à ce poste fait de
l'administration il
il a des activités qui normalement
pourrait être faite par un personnel
ayant d'autres qualifications mais ayant
aussi des rémunérations inférieures j'ai
exactement le même problème en ce qui
concerne d'ailleurs les magistrats car
beaucoup de magistrats aujourd'hui font
un travail de greffiers parce que il y a
un manque important de greffiers donc si
vous voulez dans l'esprit de la rgpp
même si ça n'est pas dans le texte de la
rgpp
il y a un vrai travail de
rationalisation qui doit être fait et
c'est la raison pour laquelle par
exemple au cours de l'année 2009
en arrivant j'ai demandé et d'ailleurs
obtenu que l'on transforme pour sur le
budget 2010 des postes de magistrat en
poste de greffier et de personnels
administratifs
parce que je pense que c'est une
meilleure utilisation de l'argent public
en la matière en ce qui concerne
maintenant le
problème des tutelles c'est
effectivement un très très gros problème
parce que les tutelles représente une
dépense de temps extrêmement importante
et pour laquelle il n'y a pas on n'a pas
envisagé effectivement des créations de
postes et en particulier de postes de
magistrats correspondante donc nous
sommes en train de travailler très
sérieusement que sur ce point parce que
la mesure a été prise mais me
semble-t-il sans avoir mesuré exactement
l'impact financier que cela pouvait
représenter
enfin en ce qui concerne le travail
pénitentiaire
oui dans la loi pénitentiaire je le dis
et c'est ma conviction profonde je pense
qu'il faut multiplier
l'activité en prison je pense qu'il faut
la multiplier parce que c'est un élément
de réinsertion sociale gérer parce que
de réinsertion psychologique également
et donc de lutte contre la récidive
en ce qui concerne les différentes
activités l'activité professionnelle
nous sommes aussi très dépendant des
ministères en charge de la formation
nous essayons effectivement de le
négocier au mieux mais en particulier en
ce qui concerne la formation
professionnelle nous avons parfois des
problèmes en ce qui concerne les
activités autres nous avons réussi à
diversifier nos partenariats et en
particulier j'ai signé il y a trois
semaines environ
une convention de partenariat avec la
fondation m6 qui fait un gros effort au
niveau des activités culturelles en ce
qui concerne les activités
professionnelles elle même j'ai passé un
certain nombre d'accords notamment avec
le medef
le problème c'est que la crise est
passée par là et que nous avons que
effectivement une certaine
un certain repli des entreprises sur
elle même
notre objectif 2009 était d'environ
10000 personnes occupées avec une masse
salariale approchant les 46 millions
d'euros le taux de réalisation de ces
objectifs
aujourd'hui est d'environ 70 % tant en
termes d'emplois que de masse salariale
c'est donc là effectivement qu'une
préoccupation une préoccupation pour
laquelle j'ai demandé une relance ou
directeurs régionaux de la pénitentiaire
que j'ai reçue la semaine dernière en
leur demandant eux mêmes sur le plan
local de voir les correspondants du
medef local de voir directement que les
entreprises dans certains cas d'ailleurs
je pense aussi et vous savez que c'était
une de mes préoccupations que j'avais
exprimé au moment de la discussion de la
loi
voir également avec les collectivités
territoriales parce que je suis persuadé
pour ma part qu il y a un certain nombre
de travaux environnementaux je pense en
particulier dans le midi à tout ce qui
concerne le nettoyage des forêts qui est
souvent à l'origine des terribles
incendies que nous connaissons ou bien
le problème de nettoyage des rivières
qui aujourd'hui n'est plus fait par
personne et qui est on l'a vu encore au
cours des dernières 48 heures entraîne
parfois des débordements extrêmement
important et des dégâts très importants
simplement parce que les rivières ne
sont pas suffisamment nettoyer alors
bien entendu ça peut pas se généraliser
au delà d'un certain niveau mais je
pense qu'il ya là de vraies possibilités
d'activités et en même temps d'ailleurs
que c'est quelque chose qui peut être
important sur le plan psychologique tant
pour les détenus parce que je pense
qu'il faut aussi moi que je suis frappé
quand je vois des détenus simplement
mettre des oignons dans des sacs de
plastique ce que des machines peuvent
faire
je pense pas que ce soit vraiment une
préparation à la sortie
en revanche quand on arrive à leur faire
faire des activités qui ont une réelle
utilité sociale et qui ont sont en phase
avec la société moderne
je pense que pour eux c'est leur donner
d'autres perspectives je vais inaugurer
demain à versailles un centre d'appels
dans une prison de femmes
il est évident que c'est quelque chose
qui est à ce moment là les remet sur un
autre chemin
en plus des possibilités qu'il peut y
avoir à la sortie parce que c'est un
secteur qui est créateur d'emploi bien
je pense que dans tout ça nous devons
travailler dans ce sens et que c'est
important d'ailleurs aussi pour
l'opinion publique
parce que si l'opinion publique voit des
détenus travailler à des travaux qui
sont aussi dans l'intérêt général je
pense que ça pourra peut-être changer un
peu le regard sur la prison et sur le
rôle que peut jouer la prison dans la
société et ça aussi c'est une mes
préoccupations parce qu'on ne luttera
pas contre la récidive
si on n'arrive pas à avoir une
intégration une réinsertion sociale
réelle et vous n'avez pas de réinsertion
sociale réelle
si vous avez une opinion publique qui
demeure aussi réticente et aussi
négative à l'égard du monde
pénitentiaire
il ya d'ailleurs des entreprises qui
prépare à l'insertion on travaille chez
des détenus qui sont en formation
professionnelle pour qu'à la sortie et
puis souvent des formules un si long
travail carcéral est une forme de
délocalisation d'activités d'emplois je
dirais que il est fils d'un carcéral ne
correspond pas au contrat de travail tel
que nous le connaissons
à aucun point de vue donc ça peut
correspondre à ça ceci dit il faut voir
ce qu est aussi la population carcérale
à qui on ne peut pas donner n'importe
quel en travail à faire n'oublions pas
que nous avons que 50% de la population
qui a de très gros problèmes
psychologiques voire psychiatriques que
nous avons une part très importante de
la population qui est illettrée que nous
avons une part importante de la
population qui n'est pas formé donc il
faut effectivement trouvé les bons
créneaux pour autant encore une fois moi
je suis choqué quand je vois faire des
choses qu'une machine peut faire parce
que vous ne réhabilite est pas un homme
en simplement le mettant à la place de
la machine
c'est une des choses qui m'a frappé
quand j'ai visité des ateliers
d'activités dans certaines prisons
merci madame la ministre d'état monsieur
le rapporteur spécial roland du luart
merci monsieur le président j'avais
trois questions mais le président n'a
pas trop générales en ont déjà mangé
deux en partie du moins
alors je vais vous parler madame le
ministre d'un des sujets qui me tient
très à coeur je dirais presque c'est un
fantasme c'est le problème des frais de
justice
grâce à la laugh nous avons fait passer
les frais de justice et en crédits de
crédit limitatif aujourd'hui alors
qu'ils étaient simplement évaluatif
avant ça a donné de bons résultats mais
il semblerait que deux nouveaux la
dynamique des frais de justice pose
problème lors du budget de 2010 je vous
avais dit que je doutais un petit peu de
la sincérité des évaluations fournies
par la chancellerie
j'aimerais savoir où on en est
aujourd'hui parce que ayant circulé dans
plusieurs cours d'appel je me suis
entendu dire que il y avait 1 est
dépassement entre 25 et 30% alors
j'aurai savoir exactement où on en est
en évolution de dépenses en 2009 par
rapport à 2008
monsieur le président il y à la fois des
efforts sensibles qui ont été faits par
la chancellerie pour rationaliser pour
rediscuter un certain nombre de contrats
avec des opérateurs extérieurs et dans
tous les domaines mais nous constatons
que également une chose et mes propos
introductif il faisait référence
c'est que vous avez une judiciarisation
de plus en plus grande de notre société
qui se traduit par une augmentation
considérable d'un certain nombre de
contentieux
or beaucoup de contentieux qu'il
s'agisse de la matière civile ou qu'il
s'agisse de la matière pénale font
référence notamment à des exercices et
c'est ce qui en explique au moins en
partie la progression des frais de
justice depuis 2007 nous étions en 2007
a380 et 8.6 millions d'euros à 400 1,7
en 2008 à 4 132 5 en 2009 et
l'augmentation principal il faut le
noter ça concerne l'action pénale et là
aussi vous avez une certaine cohérence
parce que dans la mesure où vous avez
des taux d'élucidation des crimes et des
délits qui a considérablement augmenté
cette élucidation elle repose aussi en
grande partie sur un certain nombre
d'analystes
or ne l'oublions pas le taux général
d'élucidation des actes de délinquance
en 2001 était de 22 2%
nous sommes aujourd'hui à 40% environ
enfin je suis plus ministre de
l'intérieur mais je sais que nous avions
atteint quand j'étais mise intérieur
donc l'année dernière à plusieurs
reprises 40%
donc vous avez quasiment un doublement
du nombre des affaires qui viennent et
notamment grâce à ces éléments
alors l'augmentation des frais de
justice pénale représente à peu près les
deux tiers de la dépense des frais de
justice
alors on peut ensuite le détail et si
vous voulez une part importante
ces frais de justice et fait par les
frais médicaux
vous avez 75 millions d'euros de frais
médicaux qui traduisent parce qu'il ya
une raison très particulière se traduit
en grande partie la revalorisation des
honoraires des médecins psychiatres
le décret prévoit d'ailleurs aussi et
qui est le décret de 2008
oui ça du 30 juillet 2008 le décret
prévoit d'ailleurs aussi l'application
d'un tarif majoré pour les expertises
relatives aux victimes de l'infraction
et pas simplement à l'auteur de
l'infraction
de la même façon vous avez également une
augmentation sensible des frais de
traduction et d'interprétariat ça
représente aujourd'hui 2,4 millions
d'euros et ça aussi ce sont les
revalorisations qui viennent du même
décret de juillet 2008 avec en
particulier une hausse de la première
heure d'interprétariat de 40%
donc ça explique cela les frais
d'huissier ont été également revalorisée
il se monte aujourd'hui à 15,3 millions
d'euros les frais d' enquêtes sociales
ont été également revalorisée
donc vous pouvez avoir à la fois une
vérification des quantités né dans le
même temps vous avez application d'un
décret je note également des
augmentations de prix qui ont été
constatés pour les matériel
d'interception sommes sommes dans un
autre domaine
mais comme vous avez des progrès
technologiques qui permettent de suivre
davantage
d'affaires mais c'est vrai que les
matériels coûte également plus cher
inversement ça nous avons réussi et ça
c'était un point sur lequel j'avais
insisté auprès de vous qu'il ya quelques
mois à faire baisser les frais de
réquisition des opérateurs et là nous
avons effectivement une tendance à la
baisse qui est dû à cela
moi je crois que vous êtes vous avez là
elle oriali un certain nombre d'autres
domaines ciblés notamment tous les
problèmes de transfèrements judiciaires
qu'il a aussi sa compagne de
négociations mais qui augmentent en
nombre de cas que où on en a besoin nous
avons que également eu des des efforts
qui ont été faits dans la négociation en
particulier sur les analyses génétiques
sur les transports on a eu une baisse
d'environ 1 % entre 2009 par rapport à
donc si vous voulez voilà nous en sommes
alors nous faisons effectivement des
mesures d'économies et pour cela et nous
avons des mesures qui sont à la fois des
mesures transversales et des mesures
spécifiques en ce qui concerne les
mesures transversales
l'essentiel c'est la réforme de circuit
de la dépense je pense que là nous avons
à la fois quelque chose qui nous
intéresse mais qui intéresse également
nos interlocuteurs il est indispensable
je pense que le président de la
commission des finances sera d'accord
avec moi de réduire les délais de
paiement il est indispensable de
professionnaliser les acteurs tous ceux
ci se sont effectivement des démarches
qui sont engagés mais qui ne produisent
leur effet que au fur et à mesure il ya
eu une première expérience faite dans
trois cour d'appel a compté
et dans cinq cour d'appel avait commencé
en 2008 en cinq ans d'appel l'année
dernière nous avons mis trois cour
d'appel supplémentaire et à compter du
1er juillet 2010 nous allons le mettre
en oeuvre pour la cour d'appel
d'aix-en-provence qui est une de celles
dans lequel on a toujours des problèmes
donc ce sera une bonne occasion que de
faire en tout état de cause on voit que
quand c'est mis en oeuvre on a
effectivement des résultats notamment
sur l'accélération avec d'ailleurs il
faut aussi en avoir tout à fait
conscience un rythme de consommation des
crédits qui va être plus rapide mais ça
je ne pense pas que ça gêne la
commission des finances puisque c'est au
contraire un élément de clarification
que et de bonne gestion
donc nous allons également faire de la
même façon je sais plus où je disais
j'ai réuni il ya quinze jours les chefs
de cour pour les sensibiliser à la
maîtrise des frais de justice
il pour essayer de dire qu'il devait
effectivement elle fois répondre aux
besoins mais faire très attention y
avoir une information et trans au 31
décembre il n'avait pas trop de factures
sous le coup d'un payer parce qu'il y en
a il y en a eu beaucoup
en début d'année et nous avons rattrapé
et surtout cette année nous avons réussi
à faire débloquer des décrets davance
plus rapidement ce qui est permis mais
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant qu'il
n'est pas des factures sous le coup de
ce qui ne veut pas dire non plus qu'il y
avait une évaluation de ses arriérés oui
je le crois mais je me souviens d'une
vous souvenez du chiffre ça c'est pas et
voulait passer des provisions de sang
je pense je suis pas sûr qu'on atteigne
30 millions maintenant parce que nous
avons à au 31 décembre
mais il ya des choses qui ont été opérés
normalement avec l'accélération que nous
voyons nous devrions arriver en début
d'année 2011 pratiquement à liquider
certains à condition bien entendu que
nous ayons les moyens nous permettant de
suivre l'augmentation car en la matière
mais c'est aussi vous le permettez
est-ce que vous avez encore une réserve
pour les frais de justice
parce qu'on me dit qu'à fin septembre
dont beaucoup de cours les crédits
seront intégralement consommés alors il
faut vous à une réserve
et puis et tous les arguments vous avez
donné qu'ils sont très convaincants je
crois que dans le cadrage de du budget
de la justice pour 2011 il est
indispensable qu'on ne sous-estiment pas
le volet frais de justice puisque de par
les améliorations sur le plan pénal les
consommations sont plus fortes et nous
nous pouvons que nous en féliciter
mais je crois que là-dessus la
commission des finances sera à vos côtés
parce qu' il vaut mieux avoir la vérité
sur les besoins et la justice c'est un
bien essentiel à vos côtés si vous
réduisez vos crédits
oui si vous voulez bon moi je suis très
sensible à cela puisque effectivement
l'année dernière quand je suis arrivé
dès le mois de juillet les juridictions
m'ont dit qu'elles étaient dans
l'incapacité de payer au mois de
septembre
donc nous avons réussi à débloquer ces
crédits ce qui nous permet effectivement
de ce qui nous a permis de finir à peu
près l'année avec des reports qui ont
été quand même limité en plus nous avons
obtenu au mois de mars un dégel des
crédits relatifs notamment aux frais de
justice
ce qui a permis de ne pas accumuler un
certain nombre de retards effectivement
nous sommes dans une situation où
normalement nous devrions obtenir de
nouveau les moyens nécessaires pour
permettre de répondre aux besoins des
juridictions pour la fin de l'année et
ceci
d'autant plus que nous avons renégocié
un certain nombre de choses notamment
avec des mises en concurrence qui ont
permis d'obtenir des réductions que
significatif des coûts unitaires mme un
certain nombre d' analyse je pense en
particulier aux analyses génétiques ce
qui nous permet diminué mais c'est une
sorte de course si vous voulez entre
notre capacité d'obtenir des opérateurs
de sensible réduction et d'autre part
l'augmentation des volumes et ça c'est
une réalité de ce ministère pour avis au
nom de la commission des lois des
crédits administration pénitentiaire
merci beaucoup monsieur président je
souhaiterais me glisse d'état profité de
l'hospitalité de la commission des
finances que je remercie pour attirer
votre attention sur trois points
le premier point concerne les
établissements pénitentiaires pour
mineurs
l'établissement financière pour mineurs
qui ont été décidées par la loi de 2002
qui sont désormais tous en
fonctionnement que j'ai quasi tous
visités jeu tous sauf un que je
visiterai bientôt j'avoue que moi qui
vous réclame souvent des efforts
supplémentaires et notamment des efforts
financiers supplémentaires pour
l'émission pénitentiaire c'est peut-être
la seule hypothèse où j'ai eu
l'impression malgré tout d'une débauche
de moyens et de l'absolue nécessité
d'avoir une évaluation de
là des résultats des établissements
pénitentiaires pour mineurs par rapport
justement aux moyens engagés on m'a
parlé pour 2009 de prix de journée par
exemple qu'ils étaient tous supérieurs à
1000 euros alors peut-être se trouver
ton en période de montée en charge
j'aimerais effectivement savoir ce qu'il
en est al'inverse je voulais attirer
votre attention sur des initiatives de
la pénitentiaire des initiatives
quelquefois de longue date qui me
paraissent remarquable à tous points de
vue
et j'aimerais savoir si elles le sont
également au plan financier j'incline à
penser que
elles le sont également à ce plan là
j'aurais donné deux exemples l'exemple
de casabianda la prison sans murs en
corse où le travail des personnes
détenues devrait logiquement limiter le
coot de la prison pour le nez
le ministère est ce qui amène à se
demander dans s'il ne faudra pas trouvé
effectivement d'autres hypothèses ou des
deux nouveaux casabianda peut-être d'une
autre forme pourrait être mise en place
et puis un deuxième exemple c'est la
prison de château-thierry
château-thierry quai d'une prison qui
accueille des personnes souffrant de
maladie mentale et demain dès midi
mental très lourde si elle n'était pas à
château-thierry elle devrait soit être
hospitalisé d'office soit être dirigés
vers des umd soit d'être sous être
dirigée désormais vers 18h et ça elles
sont remarquablement soigner accompagné
à château-thierry ad coûte qui à mon
avis on a sans commune mesure avec les
coûts des umd ou les coûts désuet chez
salah aussi cela permettrait de songer
peut-être à faire en sorte que je te
dirai ne soit pas une seule exception
sur le territoire français mais qu'on
puisse réfléchir à ce qu'il y ait deux
ou croient peut-être établissements de
7,2 de ce type
enfin je voulais à vous exprimer mon
inquiétude sur le fait que en 2009 il ya
eu parfois des retards de paiement en ce
qui concerne les heures supplémentaires
d'un certain nombre de personnels des
demi sachant pénitentiaire et notamment
des personnels de surveillance et dans
le climat extrêmement tendu que
connaissent aujourd'hui les pressions de
la république
je crois qu'il faut absolument éviter
que ces hypothèses se renouvelle cette
année des années à venir
je vous remercie
jean rené lecerf fouilles à cet égard
j'avais une question à vous poser sur
les reports en 2010 de près de 10
millions d'euros de charges à payer pour
l'administration pénitentiaire ce qui
est en soi un problème donc là-dessus
pouvez-vous nous nous éclairer j'espère
de rassurer
avec des obligations de payer des
arriérés de salaire sur quatre ans
décision du conseil d'état
coût estimé à 20 millions on commence la
entre-t-il dans vos dans vos budgets
madame le ministre d'état donc monsieur
le ca france il concerne les
établissements sur mineure pour mineurs
c'est vrai que le taux d'occupation de
cet établissement est extrêmement inégal
et que
cela un conduit un coût qui est
extrêmement élevé parce que dans la
mesure où vous avez un petit nombre de
mineurs parce que géographiquement il
relève de cet endroit est néanmoins vous
êtes bien obligé de faire face aux
charges générales qui sont celles de
l'établissement au total il y a deux
cent treize mineurs qui sont dans ces
conditions au premier
j'avais au 1er janvier 2010 ce qui donne
un taux d'occupation de 73%
donc effectivement les 1000 euros
calculé par mineur correspondent aussi à
ce taux d'occupation de 73%
donc il ya certainement une étude d'une
tentative de rationalisation à faire
mais c'est aussi parce que la situation
est une situation qui pour le coup là ne
dépend pas que entièrement nous mais de
déshérence si je puis dire du de la
délinquance juvénile
vous citiez le cas de casabianda
casabianda c'est effectivement ce qu'on
appelle la prison ouverte
il faut bien voir que ce type
d'établissement aujourd'hui exige
plusieurs choses d'abord casabianda est
un établissement qui est réservé à
certains types de personnes condamnées
notamment pour des agressions sexuelles
et donc ce type d'établissement
correspond assez bien à la faculté
d'encadrement de ces personnes si vous
voulez le généraliser vous ne pouvez pas
le généraliser systématiquement et à
tous les publics pénitentiaire ça c'est
le premier point le deuxième point aussi
c'est que ça ne peut pas se faire
n'importe où vous l'imaginer aisément
aussi comme élu local à voir la
perspective d'une prison ouverte
bon alors là encore c'était d'en cas
particulier mais sur le territoire ça
peut poser un certain nombre de
problèmes
donc autant je suis pour qu'il y ait des
encadrements et du travail fait à
l'extérieur un travail par la force des
choses encadré autant c'est difficile
alors j'ai demandé au secrétaire d'état
de faire une étude de voir ce qu'il en
est notamment dans un certain nombre de
pays européens et de voir ce que nous
pourrions faire il ne faut pas non plus
se faire trop d'illusions ce ne sera pas
une généralisation de cet établissement
en ce qui concerne
non pas le problème mais l'exemple de
château thierry
bon moi je ne suis pas contre ça mais il
faut bien voir que vous avez quand même
une résistance extrêmement forte venant
de la santé sur des expériences de ce
genre c'est la raison pour laquelle je
ne vais pas m'en plaindre puisque toute
façon la participation financière du
ministère de la justice est très
inférieure à celle du ministère de la
santé sur les yeux hs à deux unités
spécialement aménagé mais c'est vrai que
pour discuter dans un certain nombre de
cas avec les psychiatres et une en qu'il
ya une très très forte réticence
effectivement à ce que des soins surtout
quand il s'agit de soins lourds et
généralisé puisse être donnée à
l'intérieur des établissements
pénitentiaires nous sommes obligés de
faire on dirait qu'à un équilibre entre
les différentes formations
ensuite en ce qui concerne le problème
du paiement des heures supplémentaires
alors je sais qu'il ya eu beaucoup
d'émoi sur cette affaire des heures
supplémentaires vais toutes les heures
supplémentaires ont été payés à mon
initiative avant la fin 2009 et je les
relis gelé redit récemment il n'est pas
question d'avoir un non-paiement
quelconque à la fois des salaires et des
heures supplémentaires à la
pénitentiaire
alors ceci dit il n'empêche que il ya un
certain nombre de choses sur lesquelles
l'attention de tout le monde doit être
doit être attiré d'abord dès mon arrivée
place vendôme
j'ai été informé d'une croissance
sensible des heures supplémentaires vous
avez entre 2008 et 2009 une augmentation
de près de 30% 29% que exactement de
paiement d'heures supplémentaires donc
ça paraît quand même un peu curieux qui
est cette augmentation j'ai donc demandé
au directeur de l'administration
pénitentiaire de me faire une analyse
complète sur cette évaluation pour en
connaître les causes
et puis l'ampleur exacte alors je j'ai
eu au cours de ce premier semestre enfin
premier trimestre quand même 2010 une
analyse et et on voit effectivement
qu'il y a des causes diverses
d'abord dans le premier de ces causes
sont à la première de ces causes il y à
l problème du contentieux sur le quart
d'heure de prise de fonction sur les
postes à coupures
parce que alors début 2009 en janvier
2009 le conseil d'état a annulé
partiellement une circulaire qui datait
de 2006 et qui prévoyait la
généralisation au personnel en poste à
coupure de l'assimilation du temps de
prise de service à du temps de travail
donc le conseil d'état a dit que en fait
il a considéré que la direction de
l'administration pénitentiaire avait
méconnu l'autorité de la chose jugée
parce que en 2005 il avait annulé
conseil d'état avait annulé un
dispositif qui était est identique à
celui ci est donc
le conseil d'état ne reconnaît pas vous
reconnais plus exactement dans le temps
de travail effectif le temps de prise de
fonction pour ses personnels et rien que
ceci quand vous voulez 6000 et
effectivement ça vous fait une
augmentation que considérable et cette
décision représente nous avons calculé
entre 15 et 17 millions d'euros au titre
des arriérés dans le délai de la
prescription quadriller la description
qu'elle vieillit mal
et en la matière alors il est évident
que les agents demandent à
l'administration pénitentiaire et au fur
et à mesure nous prenons
qu'effectivement on compte tout ce qu'il
ya là de lancer de la changer c'est le
temps de passer l'uniforme ces voix-là
et l'uniforme et les consignes mais pour
toutes les professions qui s'exerce en
live sur sur voilà et sur les fêtes
d'été revient le gendarme maintenant
coupé annonc avez vous qui en charge
gendarmes et les policiers ils ont un
quart d'heure pour relier mais je n'ai
aucun souvenir d'avoir été saisi de la
moindre demande en la matière voilà donc
c'est quand même quelque chose de
sensible à la fin du mois relayé je vous
dis ce que cela représente ceci dit je
suis bien obligé effectivement dans sa
ville et ma part il faut se déshabiller
pas vrai
oui voila voila ce tu dormais encore une
fois payé bon le président artus sur les
heures supplémentaires dont je vous dis
je sais que ça a été véhiculée par un
certain nombre de syndicats mais nous
avons fait face
sinon c'est qu'ils m'empêchent pas
d'essayer de réfléchir pour voir comment
nous suivons ce dossier parce que ses
innovations sur le rapporteur général
président madame la ministre
et j'imagine que les conférences
budgétaires enfin la préparation du
budget 2011 doit battre son plein
actuellement et j'ai lu les délais les
directives du premier ministre qu'ils
font est ainsi je ne m'abuse de -10% sur
les crédits d'intervention
alors j'ai regardé au budget du
ministère de la justice enfin la mission
justice plus exactement crédits
d'intervention ces 400 millions d'euros
grosso modo enfin un peu plus dont
l'essentiel sur l'accès au droit et
ensuite la pénitentiaire alors est ce
qu'il est possible de réduire 7 mars
madame le ministre de de 10% plus nous
revenons b à c
mais nous nous revenons à ce que je
disais tout à l'heure et je le dis
d'autant plus que je disais encore ce
matin au premier ministre dans le cadre
de certains arbitrages budgétaires
bien entendu il ya des efforts qui
doivent être faits par tout le monde
il est évident que ce n'est pas la même
chose que de demander des efforts à des
ministères qui depuis 50 ans chaque
année une augmentation sensible de leurs
crédits et peut être au delà de leurs
activités et de demander les mêmes
efforts à un ministère qui depuis 50 ans
non seulement elle n'a pas eu une
augmentation équivalente de ce crédit et
qui d'autre part se trouve confronté à
un phénomène de sa propre société qui
entraîne davantage et très sensiblement
davantage d'activités que ce soit au
pénal ou que ce soit que au civil alors
en ce qui concerne les crédits
d'intervention
à vrai dire nous n'avons pas de
véritable crédits d'intervention
ce que nous avons c'est soit l'aide
juridictionnelle c'est peut-être ce don
de vous souhaitiez que je vous parle
soit elles des crédits de fonctionnement
de la pénitentiaire
mais dans un cas comme dans l'autre si
vous voulez bercy ne considère pas qu'il
s'agit de crédits d'intervention comme
on en trouve dans d'autres ministères
ça ne nous rassure pas monsieur
ordonnance ne rassure pas parce que dans
ma colonne et qui se sont bien les
crédits d'intervention mais bon je
regarde je vous signale que nous avons
50 milliards économisés par rapport à
d'autres ministères c'est quand même pas
encore très gracieux de ligier et par
ailleurs monsieur d'olivier oui mais le
président malam lounis d'état vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure
l'évolution relativement importante des
coûts de l'un des facteurs qui était la
judiciarisation par an
donc moi je m'inquiète un peu aussi
effectivement parce que est ce un mal
nécessaire et irréversible est un sport
national est ce qu'on peut strictement
rien y faire et qu'on doit constater que
la chose évolue d'année en année où il
ya t'il un moyen de le mesurer et de
freiner de réorienter j'ai vu il n'ya
pas si longtemps que ça le procureur de
la république dans mon département et
qui m'a dit je dois être alors je sais
pas si on était à fin janvier ou à fin
décembre
j'espère qu'on était à fin décembre je
dois être depuis début de l'année à 3
cents à 35 mille plaintes qui m'arrive
comme ça et qu'on est obligé de regarder
dès qu'on a le temps et c est avec ces
deux ou trois secrétaires dans le bureau
on imagine que j'étais dans l'incapacité
de lire des documents souvent manuscrit
qui prennent 20 de sa page où les gens
racontent beaucoup de choses
intéressantes
donc il ya t'il un moyen de mesurer un
moyen de freiner un moyen de le faire
quelque chose sinon on n'en sortira
jamais on continuera chaque année avec
une société qui incite chacun à les
plaintes de tous j'ai l'impression que
vraiment c'est une c'est un risque de
coûts considérables que l'on n'arrivera
pas maîtrisé oui vous avez tout à fait
raison de dire que c'est un véritable
risque qui me préoccupe et qui me
préoccupe d'ailleurs depuis très
longtemps puisque alors même que j'étais
au ministère la jeunesse et des sports
s'était pas vraiment sur la
judiciarisation et encore j'avais attiré
l'attention sur le risque représenté des
plaines de plus en plus nombreuses qui
faisait relever les taux des primes
d'assurance puisque la hausse y avait
deux les assurances se plaignaient de
plus en plus que son se retourner contre
elle y compris quand il y avait un
problème quelconque dans l'exercice d'un
sport c'est un phénomène qui a commencé
aux états unis est effectivement que
nous voyons que se développer avec il ne
faut pas le cacher parfois de la part de
certains que juriste en particulier
à pousser les gens à aller porter
plainte et je dois dire qu'il ya même
quelques quelques avocats à queue sans
doute en mal d'affaires puisqu'on a un
gros problème des avocats aussi dans ce
domaine et d'avocats qui sont au niveau
du smic dans un certain nombre
d'endroits et on envoie aujourd'hui qui
sont à la sortie des cliniques ou des
hôpitaux que pour demander aux gens si
vraiment ils n'ont pas se plaindre de ce
qui s'est passé
donc ça participe aussi à ce phénomène
alors face à ça parce que le constat je
crois qu'on le fasse faisons tous face à
cela qu'est ce que l'on peut faire
moi ce que j'essaie de faire c'est de
développer deux phénomènes qui sont ceux
en fin de 2 actions juridiques qui sont
celles de la conciliation est celle de
la médiation pourquoi d'abord c'est pas
simplement pour ne pas aller jusqu'au
contentieux et pour le coup mais je
pense que c'est aussi un autre problème
de notre société
quand vous avez une société qui
multiplie des contentieux vous avez
aussi une société qui est beaucoup plus
agressive et une société créée créé
beaucoup plus de frustration parce que
dans un procès dans une décision
judiciaire vous avez toujours celui qui
a gagné celui qui a perdu et en général
celui qui a gagné n'est jamais
totalement content de ce qu'il a gagné
et celui qui a perdu et très mécontents
et donc ça continue de créer une
crispation ou delà même du jugement
tandis que si on peut amener des
personnes voire antagonistes au départ à
se mettre d'accord sur une solution
là on prévoit leurs relations futures
qui peuvent s'établir sur la base de cet
accord d'une façon beaucoup plus pacifié
et je pense que nous avons besoin de
faire le maximum pour essayer de
pacifier notre société la france a
réellement besoin de cela donc je suis
en train de prendre sur le plan
juridique le plan des textes un certain
nombre de mesures pour développer la
conciliation et la médiation c'est à
dire notamment dans le domaine familial
par exemple il est prévu désormais que
dans un certain nombre de contentieux
il y est une conciliation obligatoire
avant de voir le juge
de la même façon vous le savez sans
doute dans des cas de divorce lorsqu'il
n'y a pas d'enfant mineur lorsqu'il n'y
a pas de vrai contentieux entre les
personnes
il paraît un peu absurde de devoir aller
jusqu'au juge ce qui veut dire aussi
toute la mécanique judiciaire qui est
mobilisée pour quelque chose ou au
départ les gens sont d'accord
donc je pense qu'il ya là des phénomènes
de gain de temps de gain d'énergie de
gains d'emplois et en même temps de
facilitation des relations que social
donc tout ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose que nous développons y compris
d'ailleurs dans le domaine commercial
il n'y a que dans le domaine prud'homale
où j'ai essayé mais les bons il existe
un certain nombre de choses les
syndicats sont réticents à aller au-delà
de ce qui existe mais pour autant ce
sont toutes ces différentes procédures
alternatives si je puis dire et que
j'essaie aujourd'hui de développer dans
tous les domaines une autre idée
également figurent dans le rapport
darrois qui consistent également
lorsqu'il i am juridictionnelle pour
éviter que l'aide juridictionnelle en
elle même soit un facteur incitatif pour
les personnes qui en bénéficient à aller
systématiquement devant l'injustice
quelle idée de demander un ticket
modérateur à l'aide juridictionnelle ce
qui d'ailleurs quelque chose qui existe
déjà dans la plupart des pays européens
nous avons peu parlé monsieur président
de ladurée dictionnaire certains
domaines dans lesquels nous sommes en
train de travailler aujourd'hui ça
représente un budget important puisque
c'est plus de 300 millions d'euros et
en même temps cela est en train
d'augmenter considérablement puisque le
nombre de contentieux au mans ça n'est
pas très satisfaisant parce qu'en même
temps les plafonds ne sont pas très
élevés et que même lorsque des personnes
ont des moyens nécessaires pour se payer
un avocat
ces personnes sont souvent amenés à
renoncer à défendre leurs droits
parce que si elles peuvent payer
l'avocat ne peuvent pas payer l'expert
or aujourd'hui vous avez énormément de
contentieux qui exige l'intervention
d'un expert dans lequel l'intervention
de l'expert est demandée et donc nous
sommes en train effectivement de voir
comment on pourrait faire nous
travaillons notamment avec les
assurances
puisque il y à un système d'assurance
juridique qui aujourd'hui ne fonctionne
visiblement pas bien puisqu'il est
utilisé dans très peu de cas et donc
nous avons dans le domaine civil bien
entendu et en dehors du divorce
une recherche aujourd'hui pour essayer
d'avoir une plus grande efficacité de
cette aide juridictionnelle civile ce
qui nous permettrait de concentrer
l'aide juridictionnelle de l'état à la
fois sur le pénal et sur le contentieux
des divorces
mais dans le même temps nous devons
également travailler à essayer de
limiter le nombre des contentieux par la
médiation et par la conciliation
compagnies d'assurance ne pourrait pas
s'inspirer de cette philosophie pour
éviter de porter la plupart des affaires
contentieux devant les juridictions nous
essayons aussi de les convaincre de cela
elles ont effectivement toujours
tendance à se dire qu'elles gagneront
davantage en allant devant le ch
la dure nous nous pensons que il faut
que aussi les convaincre d'essayer de
jouer davantage le jeu de la
conciliation fin ou de l'accord entre
temps sans que pour autant
d'ailleurs la personne concernée ne se
trouve dans une trop grande situation
d'infériorité face à la pression que
peut représenter une compagnie
d'assurance je me tourne vers mes
collègues de la commission des finances
la commission des lois et d'autres
commissions du sénat qui sont que nous
ont rejoints cet après-midi pour vous
entendre il n'y a pas d'autres demandes
d'interrogation ce qui ne serait pas un
inconvénient contenu leur grille en
consoler vous les posez une question est
entendu à l'instant dire qu'il y avait
trop d'avocats ce qui est vrai qu'ils ne
sont pas aussi conséquent pourrait
demander aux parlementaires
enfin qui veulent transformer leurs
traites de situation pour devenir avocat
de 8 et de le faire ça sera dévolue nous
avons encore moins aux premières
économies
deuxième économie mondiale et ptc de
cette réunion pour équiper vous pourriez
pas beaucoup de monde
enfin excellent flair informations sont
données alors peut-être qu'il faudrait
il aussi sur une économie modifier la
loi organique qui prévoit que le
rapporteur peut aller sur pièces et sur
place vérifier fonctionnement mis sur la
justice cette fois l'appel c'est pas la
peine qu'ils se déplacent puisque on a
déplacé le ministre parfois les rangs
c'est normal petites économies à faire
comment tout les temps que les prix là
il est passé à autre chose
d'accord je remercie le président
poncelet qui a qualifié d'excellente
cette position nous le devons à la
ministre d'état qu'elle en soit
remerciée
ainsi prend fin cette audition michèle
alliot marie la ministre de la justice a
donc été la première auditionné par la
commission des finances du sénat dans le
cadre de la préparation de l'examen du
projet de loi de règlement pour 2009
les auditions des ministres se
poursuivre jusqu'à demain
cet après-midi la réforme des retraites
va animer l'hémicycle elle les sénateurs
débattront de cette réforme en présence
d'eric woerth le ministre du travail qui
a annoncé ce matin à l'avant projet du
gouvernement sur cette réforme
il a donc officialisé le recul de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite à 62 ans
vous pourrez bien sûr suivre ce débat
sur notre antenne à partir de 16h30 est
très bonne journée